c'erano una volta un uomo gay una donna
del sud due uomini etero di antichi
spender che per facilitarci chiameremo
lo stronzo e la vispa teresa un ragazzo
in cerca di fama e di manuale
l'autista col cambio manuale
se avete voglia di perdere una giornata
non potete non visitare bologna anche
perché trovare un difetto al capoluogo
emiliano è tanto difficile quanto
trovarne un pregio patria di grandi
cantautori quali book dalla cesare
cremonini ma soprattutto gli stadio i
kiss italiani bologna e da molti
definita la dott.sa per l'università più
antica al mondo è ancora in funzione
la grassa per la sua cucina da
ostruzione delle arterie e la rossa per
via delle sue mura del suo orientamento
politico
secondi solo ai sardi i bolognesi sono
famosi per prendersela per qualsiasi
cosa e rosicare alla prima folata di
vento motivo che li ha spinti a
tappezzare di porti qui le bolognesi
invece sono famose per fare molto bene
altro
torte il gala lasagne al ragù fino alla
mortadella la storia culinaria di
bologna fa impallidire le cucine di
molte città italiane e infine bologna è
uno dei pochi capoluoghi medievali
rimasti intatti
signore e signori
solo per voi
[Musica]
ogni città tra quelle che abbiamo visto
e che vedremo a una stazione anche 23
però questa cui sicuramente sarà l'unica
che racconteremo perché ha una valenza è
un valore storico pazzesco perché nel
1980 non sbaglio il 2 agosto e letto
poco fa ci fu un attentato terribile è
stata praticamente uno degli ultimi di
quello che venne definita la strategia
della tensione in cui scopo era quello
praticamente di andare a distruggere gli
equilibri che si erano sì diventati dopo
il secondo dopoguerra e quello che
avvenne che esplose una bomba enorme non
mi ricordo di quante 25 kg che fece
crollare completamente l'ala ovest della
stazione e uccise 80 persone il tipo 200
feriti intestato degli attentati più
grossi del nostro paese e per ricordarlo
ancora oggi dopo 40 anni l'orologio
vecchio è stato lasciato nei 10 e 25 è
stato proprio l'orario dello scoppio
della bomba pazzesca bologna è la città
dei portici
grazie al cielo perché a milano trieste
torino non abbiamo trovato tempo di
merda o bologna ci ha regalato il tempo
di merda e per condividere il tempo più
brutto che abbiamo beccato fino ad oggi
abbiamo deciso di portare qui una
persona quale vogliamo molto bene il
nostro predator reds è contento di esser
venuto nella città col tempo peggiore
molto contenti perché avrà tutto esatto
per il tempo che lo becca dopo perfetto
sua reato e ha iniziato a piovere
pensare a piovere e mezzo
sembrava giusto un grado forse è bello
eh no sono un po scomodo accedere da
tipo che ne so da qui a un piano più
rialzato portami vedere
il sociale guarda le sue per della rocca
e il museo civico medievale
bella facciata questa chiesa ma non è
che il sacro graal e qui dentro
si usa niente da fare vogliamo provare a
vedere se dentro c'è il sacro grado
no però vediamo se sono curioso di
vedere la profondità del soffitto quindi
l'altezza quanto la profondità l'anti
sila tel
[Musica]
è la prima cosa del natale che troviamo
non c'è niente se ne attivo più l'aria
del natale al trieste che non c'era
neanche una vicina però in compenso
vende delle pagine graziana si sta
comprando cappello e sta crepando
rifreddo e ha fatto già un salto di 30
anni del futuro
del bottone sul noi c'è una fontanella
nolo ammettilo grazie a
dami veniva sembra un contatore della
luce passato dirlo si aprì dimostra la
piccola venezia
di è quella che bello è che se
l'aspettava messo un veneto che un we
meet me bologna è conosciuta come anche
la città dei segreti si dice che uno di
questi sia questa porticina questa
finestrella che dà sul sul fiume ma poi
ci saranno altri che scopriremo insieme
per dire una cosa terribile
io non sono un fan diciamola niente no
aspetta infatti aggrediti migrantes
timori di cui veramente
[Musica]
allora a bologna giocavano anticamente a
chi ce l'ha più grosso e quindi
cercavano di costruire sempre la torre
più grande era parla costruita la cena
ed era molto alta la realtà di bologna
[Musica]
la lasagna ok
che dicevano
molto buoni chi pensava che il mente
fosse di buona cosa fatta con le verdure
tagliate le verdure invece non lo so
sono fatti allora veramente buoni ha
fatto lo spiego cioè 3 tortelloni 3
tortellini che ora scommessa che si
mangia nel piatto
fatto un convegno
non è possibile
enrico andiamo in via maggio seconda
vinciamo ag3
elsa
[Musica]
ma questa strada quanto è bella sei tu
cammini capito centro a bologna
alzi lo sguardo finalmente arrivato
natale c'era qualcosa che nelle altre
città se non ho persi proprio a misura
d'uomo e dietro di giri e si dice perché
se c'è un cazzo ci troviamo all'interno
di palazzo podestà che si trova alle
spalle di piazza maggiore come abbiamo
detto al principio di questa nostra
visita bolognese la città di polonia
costruisce un pò di segreti
uno dei segreti è costruito proprio
all'interno di questo palazzo come
vedete sono delle volte è molto
particolari riesce a passare una
comunicazione da una parte all'altra
della volta mettendoti di faccia al muro
e riesce a comunicare con il muro
antistante
quello che sembra una persona che ha
bevuto troppo in realtà è predator che
sta parlando con gianmarco che si trova
lì voglio provarlo anche io questa cosa
e ho scelto la mia dolce metà e sarai
manuale non trovai e manuale mi sento
comunque come sa che non funziona bene
sto e pazzesco colpe ho fatto una
telefonata praticamente latina manuale
mi senti
asta botta effettivamente non ha
funzionato tutte le provate fuori dirti
una cosa sei licenziato
bene com'è possibile
il cazzo ne so
ti porto vede un altro segreto
l'elezione di nettuno ti extra di più le
lezioni di nettuno è sicuramente più
note
sono un po confuso dalle elezioni di
nettuno insomma
vogliamo dirigerlo vabbè c'è da dire
però una cosa è che lui è il dio dei
mari c'è quindi magari
sbaglio quelle donzelle stanno
spruzzando acqua dalle tette delle foto
institute e
io non so perché grazia naselli ma
scommetto che quella [ __ ] ha trovato
il punto delle elezioni
la mano e la mano una nicchia del mare
il volutamente fatto apposta certo poi
non è che quasi vede ancora il torio
sa delle cose molto interessanti tipo il
pene di lettura interessante ragazzi
coglierlo forte carina ma carina meglio
il pene di nettuno adesso andiamo a casa
di lucio dalla
[Musica]
ragazzi siamo a piazza maggiore dietro
casa e lucio dalla che aveva ben real
concerti abili c'era il pene quindi
attacca da capitano mamma mia ma che è
rotto i [ __ ] ragazza maggiorenne e
mi rompe i [ __ ] in maniera maggiore
vi sfido a riprodurre esattamente il suo
sguardo che non so come si chiama però
san petronio vi sfido a riprodurre
esattamente lo sguardo di san petronio
[Musica]
gli amici
san petronio
graziano
ma così ha fatto
[Risate]
[Musica]
rigore il telefono senza fili è una
signora muro poi le tre frecce
incastrate sul soffitto di questo porto
bellissima non c'è chi non ci ha detto
niente di bologna guardaci la battuta e
azione mai sopra torre degli asinelli
interi e sul vaso rotto però non si sa
se è vero me non esiste il telefono
senza fili si pensa che l'abbiano fatto
per i lebbrosi così riuscivano a
comunicare
altra storia si no tu ci hai detto tutto
sarà un'altra storia ma su come fare
tutte queste cose tirocinio bologna
passa lo scettro tratto
che bello
ci stiamo vivendo si vince ma l'aveva
perché tutto chiuso se non aveva anche
l'ala ovest
ma loro assistiti seguita da quella casa
fino a sera anche l'ala ed e dovevamo
andare all'università perché tipo
importantissimo anche a bologna ma
abbiamo una prenotazione per un
ristorante per cui preferiamo il cibo
alla cultura e questo ci farà morire
ignoranti massaggi banks o cene
[Musica]
andreste grande quanto il migno del
tortellino questo è proprio la prova che
sono fatti molto in casa con venezia e
non voglio che dico una cappellata dalle
mie conoscenze ovvero 0 nebrodi sui
banchi ci sono giovani piace si può
andare anche il vino hanno i propri non
è il prodotto
[Musica]
di risulta
ma è anche aggiungere
un po di settimane centinaia spero che
nel brodo che tortellini ci può andare
anche un goccio di
veramente non ci credono loro hai
studiato consigliato la scelta del turco
[Musica]
quello
la guancia il prepuzio
fatto una mangiata conto di quello che
stai mettendo al piatto poco dopo lo
faccio fanno avere della c è il sospetto
in fretta un secondo così
si ma che c'entra lasagna ferreri ragusa
ai fas è una paura
[Risate]
chiudete di capocollo così cosa poi non
è terribile la juve di che sei prevenuto
consistenza
nell'acqua
[Musica]
questo momento
sono in pugno pensa
te papigno
[Musica]
ed è così e questa puntata del blog mas
finisce qui tra
segreti segreti e altri segreti chissà
se marta l'avrà sposato per voi che
avete avuto le palle di resistere fino a
questo punto grazie ragazzi avete
stomaco da vendere adesso però uscite
scopate divertitevi e se vi vanno bene
fate i nipoti ma lecita guerra babooska
stai diventando 6 la ragazza dei
piccioni di di mamma ho perso l'aereo
con natali un cazzo e al prossimo video
[Musica]